kevin is still one of my really good
friends jenna amber
chris i see a bunch of them after naya
rivera's glee family stood on the shores
of
lake pairu to say goodbye the tight-knit
cast
took to social media to pay tribute to
their late co-star
i love you in the morning it's the
afternoon
amber riley shared this touching video
of nya and her four-year-old son
josie alongside the caption i love you
i miss you know that your family will
never have to worry about
anything i love
you but amber wasn't the only one
diana agron and harry shume jr also sent
condolences to little josie
what's the greatest thing about being a
mom everything
i mean absolutely everything you know
it's very early mornings
but i am so excited every morning it's
like christmas
authorities say nya's last moments were
likely spent
saving the four-year-old's life there
are a lot of currents
on the lake that that appear
particularly in the afternoon
the idea perhaps being that the boat
started drifting it was unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself
on monday leah michelle who is expecting
her first
child posted pics of the two people she
lost
on the same day seven years apart nya
and her ex
fellow glee co-star corey monteith
if she's gone i can't go on
naya's close pal kevin mchale tweeted
you'd be hard-pressed to convince me
that
corey didn't help find our girl today
while chris colfer reflected on his
decade-long friendship with nya
writing that being close to her was both
a badge of honor
and a suit of armor jane lynch
matthew morrison and jenna ushkowitz all
described
naya as a force becca tobin praised her
legacy of kindness
darren criss tweeted that naya was bold
outrageous and played by her own rules
kristin chenoweth shared this pic of
naya with her son
thanking her for what she gave the world
and gwyneth paltrow shared
this clip singing landslide on glee
alongside nya
and heather morris
[Applause]
[Music]
was pronounced dead on monday when her
body was discovered
following a five-day search she was
reported missing last wednesday after
she took a boat ride with her son
on lake pairu in ventura county
california
nya was just 33 years old can i
sail through the changing
while nya was grateful to have made an
impact on glee
it's just you know a dream come true she
was also thankful for the close bonds
she made on the show
that can never be broken the cast is
just so
great and it's like going to work every
single day with like 12 of your best
[Music]
sink friends in the river at dawn
send me away with the words